good day and welcome I'm Jack Van Horn from
the University of Virginia and I'm very proud
to welcome you to this edition of our 2022-2023
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
Series this lecture series is supported
by uva's integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school of data
science and through a grant from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences since
2016 the foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series is focused on the use of data
science methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling as they
pertain to differing themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences The Chosen theme for this year is
data science and the public health consequences
of the covid-19 pandemic where each Friday we'll
be enjoying presentations from the leading
thinkers on the issues promises opportunities
and hurdles associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of the covid-19 virus
these include delayed Health checkups and
treatments mental health drug abuse violence
increased obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS covid-19 virus
indeed our 2022-2023 application cycle remains
open until the end of January and we encourage
Junior faculty members working in areas such as
infectious diseases epidemiology clinical medicine
population Health as well as in data science
machine learning AI statistics and other relevant
domains please consider applying we believe
this is an exciting and engaging program we're
characterizing the secondary health effects of
covid-19 necessitates unique quantitative approach
but also new interdisciplinary collaborations
participants selected for our biomedical data
science Innovation lab program we'll leverage
these presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person Grant project development
Workshop to be held at the lodge at St Edwards
Park in Seattle Washington in June of 2023. today
I am delighted to welcome our speaker Jennifer
Ahern associate Dean for research and Chancellor's
professor at the University of California Berkeley
School of Public Health Dr Ahern is an associate
Dean as I mentioned and she earned her bachelor's
degree uh in uh Bachelors of Arts in human biology
from Brown University in 1997. she completed her
masters of Public Health and doctoral degree
in epidemiology at the University of California
Berkeley in 2000 and 2007 respectively she is
currently president of the executive committee
of the society for epidemiological research
she examines the effects of Social and physical
environment and programs and policies which
alter the social and physical environment on
many aspects of Health including violent substance
abuse mental health gestational Health Etc she has
a methodological Focus to her work including
the application of causal inference methods
and semi-parametric estimation approaches aimed at
improving the rigor of observational research and
optimizing Public Health Interventional planning
research is supported supported by a new innovator
award from the National Institutes of Health the
office and direct from the office and director at
the NIH and uh recently she was named as a Chan
Zuckerberg biohub investigator in continuing our
2022 2023 biomedical data science seminar series
theme Jennifer's lectures today is entitled
leveraging big Health Data to answer questions
about program and policy effects Jennifer is
going to present on her research leveraging Big
Data Health uh information to understand the
impacts of different forms of violence on health
and health disparities in the state of California
and the effects of programs and policies which
may influence violence our presentation will
focus on examining the injuries and deaths due
to Legal intervention amongst young people and
the examination of the effects of gun shows
on firearm injuries in the post-implementation
period of California's 1999 gun show legislation
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via YouTube and if you're watching
via YouTube thank you so much for joining us also
our specially selected 2022 2023 biomedical
data science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are encouraged to submit any questions
they have via the zoom chat sessions I will
synthesize these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that Jennifer welcome and thank
you so much for doing this for us we are really
looking forward to your lecture wonderful thank
you so much Jack that was a lovely introduction
um I will just jump into it um you now have a
great sense of what I will be talking about today
um I do want to call out that I will be
talking about as Jack mentioned uh various
forms of violence um and so if that's a you know
a difficult topic for you this this may not be the
best to talk to join and you know of course feel
free to take breaks as we go along as you need
so to give some sense of what I'll cover today
talk a bit about violence as a health problem
and I'll talk about the research
we've been doing within that realm
with a couple of examples and wrap up with
some discussion and and sort of the future
directions that we're thinking about
for this work in my research program
it's probably obvious to all of you just
from sort of day-to-day life looking at the
newspaper and so on the violence is really a very
devastating health problem in the United States
um we're often most aware of this due
to the most high profile incidents that
tend to to make the headlines such as
police violence mass shootings and hate
motivated violence all of which have
been unfortunately increasingly common
in recent years but it's also important to
remember that the largest burden of violence is
actually um you know those those events that are
somewhat less high profile less obvious perhaps
um in the form of General Community violence
self-directed violence and also domestic violence
um so let's just take a little minute to
put violence in the context of sort of
burden of disease burden of mortality in the U.S
um this figure shows um the leading causes of
death in the United States in recent years and
as you might anticipate we have heart disease at
the top followed closely by cancer you can see for
2020 covid-19 coming in there at number three
and in terms of injury related causes of death
um really the only one making this top 10
list is the unintentional injuries or also
known as accidental injuries um but this overall
burden sort of masks some important heterogeneity
um that that makes violence a somewhat unique
um contributor to our burden of mortality
um and so now this is the the top five uh
leading causes of death um you can see that
along on the left side and then along the top we
have the different age ranges of the population
and while you can still see unintentional
injury as playing the primary role in
mortality for those at Young ages from
the age of one all the way up through 44.
um you also can start to see the violence
related causes of mortality coming in the top
um top two three and four positions for children
as young as one um going all the way up into mid
40s and so we can see violence related causes
playing a major contribution to mortality that
we think about as being perhaps premature or
coming early in the life course when it may be
um uh very devastating for
those affected in their families
um so violence is an interesting area to
do research in um for a variety of reasons
uh violence has generally been framed societally
as an issue that we handle with criminal justice
and law enforcement but I think there are a lot
of valuable things that health or public health
approach can bring to this that I'll get to in a
moment um another important piece of this is that
research on violence is very highly politicized
due to the connection with guns or firearms
um there's a whole bunch that could be said
here but just to highlight a few of the issues
um since 1996 when the Dickie amendment was passed
there's been a dramatic curtailment of research on
violence it's a Prohibition on the use of federal
funds to Advocate or promote gun control which of
course doesn't directly say research but
they've been interpreted essentially as
um you know intended to curtail work on on
violence and specifically gun related violence
overall and was interpreted as such by many of
the funding agencies in addition there's the T
heart amendment that since 2003 has limited data
on Firearms trace and that's has some implications
for research it actually creates more law
enforcement challenges than research challenges
um but despite all these sort of
complexities and challenges I think
um being sort of in the among the parts of
society trying to deal with the question of
violence I think uh health approach or
health lens has really led to some very
interesting and productive additions to how
we are addressing violence some examples are
um prevention approaches that address
the contagion aspect of violence such
as community-based violence interruption or
hospital-based Interruption a variety of policy
approaches to restrict means and de-escalate
situations such as waiting periods a lot of really
interesting work around modifying the environment
such as reclaiming vacant Lots creating positive
spaces in communities to try to reduce violence
and then of course in public health we think a
lot about looking Upstream to the more fundamental
causes that may be driving violent interactions
and these 10 to be very sort of fundamental things
such as economic opportunities education and so on
so that's a sense of violence as a health problem
and now I'll talk a bit about the research I've
been doing in this space um so the vision I
had for this this started back around 2013
was that if I could develop a sort of robust data
infrastructure that would allow me to capture and
measure events of violence in the society
that having that sort of Base uh base of
um robust data would allow research to be built
upon that could that could help us identify
um the things that are driving violence and
perhaps identify effective interventions when
this started I was focused on California um with
the um and that was on with a NIH director's new
innovator award funding and then fortunately
recently we received funding from the trans
Zuckerberg by a hub investigator program that
will allow us to continue this work as part of
that we are you know expanding both to you know
some more national uh Geographic scope as well as
digging into some new kinds of data sources that
can be leveraged so to say a little bit more about
what these data look like we've been building
this health database from Statewide data in
California from 2005. forward you know right now
we're sort of in the 2000 2021 Zone approximately
in terms of the data we have in hand and this
includes mortality records from the California
Department of Public Health their office of
vital statistics and then hospital system data
specifically emergency department and inpatient
Hospital data and these are the discharge records
that we get from the California's Department
of Health Care access and information
um we're working now towards some more National
sources as I mentioned such as National crime
data and mortality data we've been doing some
interesting new work using Google Health Trends
data so how do we use these sources to measure
violence uh while we have the deaths from the
mortality records and injuries from those treated
in hospitals and then among those records we use
the ICB codes they're known as e-codes or
external cost of injury codes to identify
the source of the injuries so whether it was due
to um you know an assault type of interaction
or if it was self-directed and those sorts of
details to be able to capture and measure the
the rates of different forms of violence so we
coordinate the sort of event-based data I guess
you could call it with the denominator data
from the different Geographic and demographic
units from the ACs and so we then have counts and
rates of a variety of different forms of violence
related injuries and deaths um for you know a
wide range of geographical and temporal scales
okay so I'll share a couple of examples of
projects we've done using these data to give
you a sense of the kind of uh work we've been
doing what its value is and um you know sort
of what we're thinking about moving forward so
some of the work we do I think of as uh sort of
investigating patterns or you might call it more
descriptive um it's very um really allows to sort
of monitor the burden of uh violence-related
injuries and deaths in the population over
time by demographics it's been very valuable for
both generating ideas for things that might Merit
research and also for putting the findings that
we have for more analytical projects into context
um and so I've I find this to be actually
quite an interesting piece of what we do
um we've so we've looked at temporal demographic
and other patterns in community violence suicide
and self-harm as well as Police use
of force related injuries and deaths
and I thought I'd share a bit more detail
on one example project looking at injuries
due to Police use of force among
Children and adolescents in California
so some background on this in the past few
years I would say it's become much more broadly
to people's attention that police violence is
really critical issue impacting populations in
the U.S and we know that these experiences are
associated with adverse Health both of course
at the moment of injury but also throughout the
lifetime um exposure during this early period
childhood and Adolescence may be particularly
harmful um and at the time we did this work
there was uh only one other study that looked
at injury burden among Youth and a lot of the
um studies were sort of limited in the sense
that you know with small numbers it's hard to
um break the rates down into combinations of
for example race and sex and so with our large
data resources we thought we'd probably have
something to add to our understanding of this
the burden of injury because we're able to look
at all of these very finely divided up groups
um the work to date had documented the mechanisms
through which youth come into contact with the
police through structural marginalization and
had documented stress-related Health outcomes
such as impacts on Mental Health that result from
these sort of violent interactions with police
and so here's one of the findings from the paper
this shows the rate of um what's called the
ICD code is legal intervention injuries so it's
injury due to an interaction with law enforcement
and this is injuries through the emergency
department as well as inpatient hospitalization
and this is among youth so um people age
0 to 19. and these are the rates over time
um and split up by race ethnicity groups and
so what probably jumps out most obviously here
is the dramatically higher rate of injury due
to law enforcement experienced by black youth
and as I mentioned we're also able to divide this
up by different combinations of demographics and
so we're now looking at the overall rate um
over that time frame but we've divided it
by age groups so the cop panel shows us the
younger um age group the 10 to 14 year olds
while the bottom panel shows us the the
older adolescence the 15 to 19 age group
um and we can again see the um the pattern
that we observed in the prior plot of
um black children being much higher having a much
higher rate of injury due to Legal intervention
but it's also interesting here to see particularly
if you focus on the younger children and the top
panel that you can see the rate for black boys of
course is the most elevated but the rate for black
girls is actually very high and higher than that
for any of the other groups whether you're looking
at boys or girls and so this just really shows
the differential impact of this form of Violence
by race ethnicity in a way that's obviously
going to be very harmful and needs attention
um and so overall we conclude we're seeing that
um the rate among Youth Of course is much lower
than it would be among adults um but there is
quite a degree of differential impact across
these demographics and in particular black
children and adolescents a much greater burden of
injury than youth from other racial ethnic groups
um it's also notable that if we think of
the comparison to White youth there are a
lot many groups that have higher rates um black
youth of course but also American Indian Alaska
native Hispanic and other and multiple race all
had higher rates than those of white children
and having these large data allowed us to really
dig into intersections between race sex and aged
and this revealed this somewhat unique impact
among black girls um and you know this is um
something that's consistent with work in the
past that's documented uh what could be thought
of as adultification of black girls um and
the perception of them as more threatening
so that's one example of the kind of work we can
do we have done descriptively looking at patterns
of different forms of violence and now I'll shift
into talking about work we do looking at how the
physical and social environment and policies
and programs impact different forms of violence
um in some of this we've looked for example
at more local things such as local violence
prevention programs that are trying to reduce
Community violence we've looked at some sort
of Statewide phenomena policies um
and I'll provide one example today
um one part of starting to work with these data is
um I'm not sure you know sort of what disciplines
are represented by folks watching the talk but in
epidemiology our sort of standard study designs
tend to be you know cohorts following people
individuals over periods of time that sort of
thing um and these are very different sorts of
data um and so working out what would be the most
effective ways to work with them and still have
strong interpretation of results for analytic
Studies have been part of our kind of Journey
um and you know we've come up with a used a whole
bunch of different methods depending on exactly
what we're doing but some examples are here um and
so that's been another interesting piece of this
so the example study I I thought I'd share
today um is you could think of it as sort
of a intersection between looking at a
change to the physical environment and
um looking at a policy effect um and this
is looking at the relationship between gun
shows and Firearm related deaths and injuries and
the effects of those on Californian populations
um so for some background um gun shows for
those who may not be familiar with them
um they're events that set up uh sort of
temporarily over usually over a weekend
um and offer a temporary source of new and used
Firearms ammunition and related equipments tend to
be setting up in convention centers or Fairgrounds
there are over 4 000 annually in the U.S they're a
relatively small portion of animal firearm sales
estimated between four to nine percent but they
tend to be uh or they can be dependent on where
they are exactly places where they're somewhat
left less oversight and guns purchased or acquired
here are disproportionately implicated in crimes
and when we did this work there had been very
limited research on gun shows and Firearm injuries
um this one paper by Duggan looked at um the
relationship in California and Texas and found
there was no connection between gun shows and
Firearm injuries and deaths but you know then
in sort of their probably their worst nightmare
scenario they get a variety of commentaries on
the problems with this study and so among the
problems were that they had incomplete assessment
of gun show events that they were underpowered
and quite importantly that they had ignored the
10-day waiting period in California so they were
essentially looking at outcomes at a time when
the guns would not yet have been acquired by the
people purchasing them so we thought in a variety
of ways that we could do better and so we sort of
went from there and tried to look at this question
um more rigorously we thought that it was
certainly reasonable to think gun shows May
increase firearm injuries but also that it
might be interesting to look at whether we
could see any effects of the differences in State
Firearm regulations and that that might modify
the relationship between gun shows and Firearm
injuries there's quite a lot of work showing how
there are flows of firearms from less restrictive
to more restrictive States and that that you know
of course limits the effectiveness of in-state
regulations of people just travel out of state
and so we thought we might be able to see some
effect of this in the setting of the gun show
so our objective was to look at whether gun shows
were related to short-term increases in firearm
deaths and injuries in the nearby regions and
to look at whether this differed by the state
in which the gun show was taking place and so
um we sort of leveraged the natural variation
in the timing and location of gun shows that
were taking place both in California and then
in our neighboring state Nevada you can see
we share quite a lot of our border with Nevada
um we used a difference in differences approach
to look at this question and so I'll walk through
the pieces of these differences the first was
looking at the rates of firearm deaths and
injuries in the two weeks before each gun show
and comparing that to the two weeks after each
gun show and accounting for the 10-day waiting
period in the case of the California shows
so that's for California shows um within a
traveling distance around the show I'll talk
a bit more about how we Define the distance and
then we made this comparison um the entire time
looking at California populations but looking at
California populations exposed to gun shows in
California versus California populations exposed
to gun shows taking place in Nevada and so in
Nevada there's really two primary locations Reno
up near where the figure is here and then also Las
Vegas where there are a substantial amount of
shows very close to the border with California
um the decision of the two-week window before
and after was really motivated by wanting to
have a really sort of tight um tight time
around the show to avoid there being other
things that might be changing during that time
frame um but we also checked the sensitivity of
the results to bigger and bigger and
smaller time Windows around the show
so the way we're thinking about this design is
that each region is serving as its own control
because we're comparing rates immediately before
and after the show where you know very little
else will have changed within that very short
time frame if we keep the geography the same
so that was our general design and then we needed
a source of data for the gun shows themselves the
locations and dates and so we first thought we
would approach this using a sort of uh I don't
know fancy high-tech approach and we went um
to the internet and thought we could use sort
of web scraping approaches to identify past
shows we used the Wayback machine to restore
old versions of websites that had posted dates
and locations of gun shows um and this seemed
to be working reasonably well except that when we
went um to try to compare what we were able to get
um from the internet to sort of more old-school
approaches of just looking through uh gun show
magazines which is where um you know all
the dates and locations are posted we found
that our assessment was incomplete and in
particular that as we were going further
back in time we were losing more and more of
the gun show events relying on the internet
so uh we decided we need to rearrange our
approach and go a little lower back to start with
and so in doing this we started with the
physical gun show magazines as the primary source
and we had access to these because a colleague my
colleague Aaron went to mute at Davis had for many
years been subscribing to these magazines and
had been storing them in a place that he calls
the shed which sits behind his office at UC Davis
and in the picture is Krista and Garen Krista work
worked with me at the time and she also lived
out there near Davis so she went and picked
up this giant giant bins of magazines and brought
them to us at Berkeley to start working with them
before they could Venture into the sheds
there was an issue of black widow spiders
that had to be dealt with but no one
was well I suppose some spiders were
probably harm but no people were harmed in
the recovering of the journals from the shed
that's Ellie who's the first author on this
work working in the you know the copy room
with all of these magazine scanning then she
had to convert it all over to being you know
readable characters uh did a whole bunch of work
to clean up the addresses and after all of that
work we had somewhat over 900 gun shows over
our time frame in both California and Nevada
so we have our gun shows we have our outcome
rates before and after them and then we needed
to Define our uh sort of geographic uh
range around each show and so what we
decided to do was create a unique region that
we determined to be exposed to the show based
on the sort of zip codes around each show
and we decided that for the California shows
um people would probably be willing to travel
about an hour uh to get to a show but probably
not a lot more and this is because it based on the
geographic and temporal distribution of shows If
you're willing to drive about an hour there will
be a show you can get to within a couple of weeks
at any given time and so it seemed unlikely
that people would go a whole lot further if
there'd be in most instances if there would
be another show you know a week later or so
um we thought that for the shows in Nevada um
there might be a willingness to go somewhat
further uh there's shows in Nevada have quite a
lot of differences in terms of what you're able
to acquire there and the types of regulations that
um are or are not present um and so we thought
about two hours was reasonable for how long
people might travel to get to a show in Nevada
um and so as I previously noted we're
looking at the rates in these Geographic
zones Within These driving distances uh
two weeks before and after each show and
for California that two-week window starts
after the 10-day waiting period concludes
uh we used a pretty straightforward regression
modeling approach um with random effects on the
show's month indicators and a population offset
an estimated rate ratios associated with the gun
shows in California shows in Nevada those
are both the sort of first difference and
then we compared the two to each other for the
difference in differences comparing the Nevada
shows to the California shows our main question
was just about overall firearm injury but we also
stratified by different types of firearm injury
to see if there were any revealing patterns there
so here are main results you can see that the
adjusted rate ratio for the California shows is
very much on the null there's no elevation in
the rate of firearm injuries and deaths after
California shows however there's quite a
substantial elevated rate of gun related
injuries and deaths following Nevada shows and
you know with one null and the other about a
70 percent increase rate the difference in
differences estimate is also approximately
a 70 percent increased rate comparing the
Nevada gun shows to the California Ventures
and when we divided the analysis to look at
self-directed interpersonal and unintentional
firearm injury we found the strongest
associations were present for the interpersonal
um violence-related injury but that there were
elevations in the rate for all of the forms
um of firearm injury all right
so what do we make of all of this
um it could be that California which has quite
strict regulations around gun shows may be
deterring firearm acquisition and whatever
you know activity was planned based on that
firearm acquisition while the Nevada's regulations
which um are very minimal and it did not and that
there's of course a huge amount that could be said
here but some examples of differences between the
states California requires Universal background
checks and has a very large and comprehensive set
of gun show regulations that are strongly
enforced Nevada does not regulate much of
anything around gun shows and we know from other
work that legal activity is much less common in
states that have these types of regulations of
the shows compared with um places that do not
um another um possible explanation is that we're
seeing some displacement so because California's
strict regulation means certain things sort of
can't be achieved at uh California gun show it
may be motivating travel to Nevada um for
acquisition of certain Firearms or types of
ammunition or whatever might be of interest
that's simply not available in California
and there is quite a lot of work documenting
gun trafficking between our these two states
now of course this is a you know this is an
observational study we've done everything
we can to try to make um you know sort of
eliminate other explanations by uh looking
you know comparing each region to itself
very short time frame uh before and after
but of course there could be some other source
of bias like uncontrolled confounding we did a
lot of work to try to convince ourselves that that
was not very likely for example we did a negative
control analysis where we looked at non-firearm
injuries and deaths as the outcome in all of
those results were null which was reassuring that
there wasn't some other source of bias we also did
a quantitative bias analysis to try to figure out
if there were some unmeasured confounder how would
it need to behave what kind of confounder would
it need to be and essentially it would have to
be quite a strong confounder it would have to be
somehow following the same Geographic and temporal
distribution of the gun shows very uneven between
California and Nevada and changing markedly in the
weeks before and after the shows so that's the
sort of thing those are the properties it would
have to have and there's nothing that we were able
to think of that would have had those properties
so in conclusion it seems like California's
policies regulating uh firearms and gun shows
may be quite effective in preventing acute
increases in farm injuries and deaths and
it is important to remember that's really all
we're doing here by focusing on the Windows
right before and after it's just acute changes um
it would be interesting to look at this in other
settings where you have states with um you know
stricter and less strict firearm environments to
see whether similar types of phenomena are taking
place of course better understanding in general of
patterns of acquisition and use of firearms
are needed and this is just one small piece
of a very complex puzzle that is firearms and
Associated injuries in the U.S all right let me
just see how I'm doing on time it's okay um so a
few points for discussion before we go to the Q a
um we're continuing to develop approaches uh to
work with these you know health related Big Data
um with novel analytic methods to study questions
about different forms of violence and as I noted
some of this is kind of in the health monitoring
hypothesis hypothesis generation realm and then
the other piece is trying to really generate
evidence from these observational data that
can help us understand what programs and policies
might be effective at mitigating different forms
of violence we're working towards expanding to
National scope and broadening the sources we're
using these are just a few of projects that
are sort of somewhere in between upcoming and
underway looking at gun stores and sales and
gun related injury also alcohol Outlets some
of that work is actually uh just come out in a
health in place if you want to check that out
um we have worked underway looking at
marijuana policy changes and violence
pandemic related changes in violence have
been very interesting um and then a variety
of other continuing investigations into people's
injuries due to law enforcement interactions
um I think some of the things we've gleaned
from working with these type of data is that
once you have this sort of basic infrastructure in
place um you can have very sort of time and cost
efficient use of those resources because you
know we do put a lot of work into making them
getting them ready to use but once that's been
done the data are at the ready and then can can
be combined with other efforts that may be more
time intensive or detailed such as the work that
we did Gathering gun show data and also other
work that's underway on more kind of detailed
local policy assessments where that can now be
coordinated with data that are are ready to go
um obviously having you know the
general population data um allow us
to have estimates that are very applicable to the
areas under study it's a complete population data
and having the very large numbers particularly
you know California is an enormous State
um allows us to really divide up the data into
lots of different population subgroups that may
be of interest and important for understanding
Health disparities uh where in settings if we
had [Music] um smaller smaller general population
data that we might not really be able to report
reliable rates and so having these large data
has been really beneficial yeah there are lots
of things that would make things better for us
one would be increasing the timeliness of data
availability California actually does a great job
of having these um Statewide resources coordinated
and available for research but the process
is for acquiring them can be you know time
consuming and you know we there's quite somewhat
of a lag certainly a couple year lag between
um when you know events are occurring and
when we can actually be looking at the data
another interesting area we've been working on
is more linkages among these data sources and
I think this is going to be a really fruitful
exciting place for a lot of new work we've been
working on some of these for example linkages
between birth files with hospital records and
um also amongst hospital records to understand you
know events that preceded later violence related
injuries so I'm really excited about this area
we've been investing a lot in this linkage space
so that's what I had to say to all of you today um
this is you know I'm sort of the representative of
a huge collaborating group that's worked on this
um I couldn't none of this would have happened if
it weren't for all of the folks uh acknowledged
here uh collaborators at Berkeley also many other
places to Emperor to UCSF NYU Colombia Davis
um and of course all of our funders have been
critical uh to making this possible so that's
what I've got and uh happy to take any questions
Jennifer thank you so much for sharing all this
with us this is uh this is a lot of work that you
guys have done I thank you for sharing it with us
I'm kind of curious if you have look you mentioned
um kind of looking at the kind of interaction if
you will between guns and and Alcohol and Other
say drugs I'm curious because you have Nevada in
your equation of course Nevada is famous for many
things one of which is the gambling industry
and I noticed that two of your major locations
that you were looking for gun shows were both in
Reno and Las Vegas which are kind of destination
you know locations for people to they may not
necessarily reside in Nevada but they may go
to Nevada to go to Reno for the entertainment
gambling industry you know going to shows and uh
you know Cirque du Soleil or whatever it is at the
same time is there may be gun shows I'm curious
if you have looked at any of those other factors
that sort of differentiate Nevada from California
yeah that's a really great question um I don't
think we have um essentially there's complete
um co-occurrence if if you know what I mean
you know like those two areas just are are
characterized by a pretty substantial gambling
industry I guess argue certainly Las Vegas may
be more more than Reno but both you know
both have um that is a big Focus um so we
haven't but that's a really interesting
question I have to give some thought to
um how we might be able to dig into that more
but yes there are so many differences between
the two states [Laughter] yeah this is just one
of many but uh I was just kind of curious about
that and I'm also curious about um the role
of things like the various State and National
say Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms
or something as a potential source of data
or other information that might be helpful for
you as you're pursuing some of these activities
um yes so there the work that I was just a few
slides back I mentioned that um where we looked at
uh firearm stores and Firearms sales connected to
firearm injuries um that was in collaboration I'm
gonna now get I'm I probably can't remember the
correct name but this is sort of the California
um version of you know that sort of agency that
oversees firearms and um it's been a little bit
tricky they had had provided data but then
declined to provide more data and it's not
super clear exactly what's going on there but at
any rate we have data for um I think it's about
eight or ten years of time and so we were able
to use those data to coordinate with the health
health related violence data that we've talked
about and that was how we were able to look at the
relationship between uh firearm stores and sales
from those stores related to farm injuries um
maybe I mean if data is the you know the Grist for
this Mill and uh one of our listeners was asking
about how you um also apply Google data for some
of your work and if you could say a little bit
more about how you do that um yeah yeah I'd
love to say say a little more about that so
um we were so what we were we may do more
but what we've done so far is we were
interested in whether we could use the Google
Health trans data to capture some of what
might be going on with domestic violence
over the period um where the pandemic hit
because we were very worried that all
of the kind of usual ways of monitoring
uh something like say child maltreatment would
suddenly be impacted so for example children are
not physically going to schools in many cases and
so they're not you know there's no teacher to see
you know if they seem to be having experienced
an injury or whatever the situation might be
um and so we thought you know we we can't really
rely on the usual types of data sources and so we
wondered whether we could use Google search data
so essentially it's um you um you come up with
um a sort of set of Search terms that you're going
to use to try to see the volume of search on a
certain topic and to use that to monitor that
you know it's obviously not directly capturing
the phenomenon but whether whether it could be
a way to capture some aspect of the phenomenon
um there's a paper that we had come out I think
in maybe just the last year led by Kristen Newman
um I think it was an American Journal of
epidemiology that did a really nice job
outlining our strategy to to go through the search
term refinement process which you know it was one
of those things that when we started it we sort
of thought oh no problem we'll just you know get
in there and grab the search data and go on our
merry way and it turned out just the process of
figuring out how to come up with the Search terms
and all of that was kind of the bit one of the big
most challenging pieces um of uh working through
the process I would say in addition probably the
biggest asterisks I would put around working with
a Google Health Trends API data is that what you
receive out of um the sort of the outcome or the
the search information that you get is a scaled
relative search volume and so the fact that it's
relative search volume really complicates things
when you're trying to look at the effects of
something like the pandemic where we could
imagine that the pandemic the occurrence of the
pandemic may have just directly impacted people's
online behavior in a very sort of substantial
way at least possibly and so that always sort of
lurked as a challenge was um because we knew that
we were always we were relying on this relative
search volume metric where there could be have
been a big change in overall search Behavior so
anyway that's maybe more that you wanted to know
but Krista Newman's paper is really fantastic
um in outlining the details of how we went through
that process and in a way that would make it
accessible for you know someone else to sort of go
in there and try to measure their own phenomenon
Jennifer are you getting any sense of what
motivates people to want to go to gun shows
um you know as a you're basically they're going to
the gun shows you're collecting the data on that
they've they've come are you getting any sense
of like why and has that changed pre-pandemic to
post-pandemic oh that's a great question um I
mean so it's gun shows are pretty interesting
so if you think about um a gun show in California
so California is extremely heavily regulates a lot
of things around uh firearms and because of the
10-day waiting period you actually can't leave
a gun show with a gun if you purchase a gun at
a gun show you would then pick it up after the
10-day waiting period from a nearby retailer um
and so you know it's an opportunity for people
who are interested in guns to obviously you
know physically interact with with the guns and
um you can they can purchase ammunition um you
can leave a California gun show with ammunition
um but you know for people where they see guns
as an important part of their activities and
lifestyle and Recreation it's a chance to go
you know check out the latest items and you
know much like I don't know people might
do for another another topic of you know
the fishing fishing or enthusiasm and you know
there you might have an image of what they're
like but it's sort of like a family affair
you know there's families there's kids there's
food there's entertainment it's sort of like
a you know a gathering event and um because
in California there's so much regulation around
it um there's it's actually not too surprising
that you're not seeing um substantial jumps in in
firearm injury immediately after them I would say
um the contrast is so interesting though isn't
it I mean you describe like a family friendly
atmosphere and yet the the one of the results
is the violence that you know you're measuring
or making measurements of and I you know curious
if you know there's I don't know something that's
like a catalytic kind of uh of a effect is coming
from you know gun guns in the news media you know
every night we turn on the news and you know it's
like oh this person was shot or this person there
was a gun violence and we experienced that here
at UVA we uh University of Idaho is just going
through this now it's affected not only University
of Idaho but also Washington State University
other you know school shootings around the country
and just kind of like wonder what's what's driving
this so is it video games is it glamorizing
gun violence in Hollywood you know like what
goes somebody says you know gee you know what I'd
like to do is go to a gun show and buy a gun and
then go you know hurt people I don't know what's
what's triggering that uh and I realize this is
I'm probably in that zone you're nervous about but
uh it's it does affect Public Health obviously and
it's something that I'm wondering if there's
something that's causal that you can tap into
well I do want to clarify that when I'm talking
about these sort of you know relatively uh
unharmful events I'm specifically talking about
the version of gun show that takes place in
California due to the substantial regulation
um the story is very different in the Nevada
shows so there's very little regulation you
can purchase things like assault rifles you
can leave that day with that assault rifle you can
purchase types of ammunition that are not allowed
in California and there's a lot of documented
activity um it among gun shows that are not
subject to much regulation there's research
showing there's a lot of activity that takes
place for example in the parking lot that may
be you know there's no oversight whatsoever so
I just wanted to make sure that was clear I'm not
saying gun shows in general are no of course yeah
you know region to region I mean what happens
in Texas is you know probably maybe even maybe
even more unconstrained than what you're seeing
in Nevada um which also brings me to wonder you
know how does what you're seeing here do you have
any comparisons with you know other countries not
just other states but you know like in the UK or
the European Union Asia Africa Australia where you
know there was a very famously a big kind of gun
buyback um act thing a number of years ago now and
gun violence for the most part in Australia has
gone to you know almost nothing and I'm just kind
of curious if you know violence in general whether
it's gun violence or anything else that's uh you
know any events or activities if you have any way
to compare how the U.S does with other countries
um well for well probably not for better for
worse just probably for Worse um the United
States is very unique um we have so many guns in
this country uh our country is just simply a wash
in firearms and there is nowhere else that is in
that situation and so what happens here really
there isn't really a comparable certainly not a
comparable amongst the sort of um you know higher
income settings yeah and so it's hard you know
when something happens in the UK I mean it's just
the the whole the context there just the guns are
not everywhere the way they are here so yeah the
nature of violence is quite um specific the way we
experience it is quite specific to our situation
that's the truth um what lessons did you learn
from a quantitative modeling point of view that
might be of interest to people who are interested
in kind of working with similar data or things
that you would like to see done differently or
where can data science help play a role here
yeah that's a great question I mean uh there's
a bunch of different methods we've found to be
useful for working with these kinds of data so
um I didn't present an example using this method
but we we've done this in a few different
studies where we use a synthetic control
approach and that's an area that's developed
with a lot of sort of interesting data science
work bringing in machine learning into the
into the estimation of the synthetic control
we did work looking at the relationship between
the mental health services act in California
which is a sort of enormous investment in public
Mental Health Services that was made based on a
tax initiated in around 2006 and we found the
synthetic control approach to be very effective
there because um in that case we're looking at
a Statewide outcome and so then if you try to
think about you know well what other state in
the country is the best sort of counterfactual
comparison for California it's maybe not obvious
that any one state can really serve that role very
well but the synthetic control approach says
you know you don't have to pick just one well
it analytically comes up with the best weighted
average of possible control units that um that
best matches the sort of the pre-treatment or
pre-intervention Trend in your intervention unit
um so that was has been really interesting
to learn about and very productive for
addressing these um questions when you
have the just big aggregated rate type
data which is often what we're dealing with
um and another interesting approach we've
um been working on some of this was used in
the work looking at gun stores and gun sales
is to basically convert what we have into
case Control Data I don't know how familiar
the audience is with that it's you know
an epidemiologic design where you have
uh a set of uh cases meaning individuals who had
the outcome of interest but then you have a sample
of people that are controls um and essentially
the controls are a sample from the underlying
cohort that gave rise to the cases and um we've
done some really interesting things combining our
population-based case data with Control Data from
the ACs so essentially um treating the ACs as if
it were a population I mean it is a population
study but then sampling individuals from the
ACs to serve as controls and that's worked quite
effectively at kind of restoring an individual
level uh data structure it's a little Limited
in terms of the covariates you have but
um I guess those are two things I would highlight
that have been really interesting from doing this
work I think one of the impressive things about
your presentation is uh and one of our uh viewers
commented on this as well your uh old school
paper media you're looking at gun magazines
to basically accumulate your data and do you have
any other General suggestions for how people might
deal with situations like that where you know
possibly the data is incomplete or it's biased
um but it's in magazines or other you know not
digital media and you have to kind of go and find
it what other creative ways and creative locations
like libraries or crowdsourced data collection you
know what other kinds of things would you think
of [Music] um well I mean certainly any you know
print may be the solution I mean for some for a
lot of these things there's no um easy work around
I mean that sort of we started this thinking
we could be clever and and do this morning but
in the end there was no um substitute for what
um epidemiologists Call shoe leather work which
is just slogging through the slogan sometimes
that's the way to do it right and getting the
information I mean for the the policy assessment
work that my colleague is doing and she's going to
coordinate it's around changes to marijuana
policy which in California have been very I
mean she's the expert on it so my my statements
are going to be very sort of General on it but
the gist is you know obviously we've had this
shifting marijuana policy environment and then
um there's a lot of discretion for local um towns
and cities to make their own decisions about what
they're going to allow and not allow and so you
have all you have both uh the legalization but
then immediately all this heterogeneity and look
exactly what's allowed where and that's of course
then also shifting with time and so she's been
doing um what you know might be called Legal
epidemiology where she's characterizing localities
based on going through documentation of their laws
um and you know to my knowledge there's not a
super quick easy way to do that requires you
know reading reading the laws and deciding how
to classify so I think that's so interesting
too because you know while we're on the one
hand we're just awestruck by the amount of
data that we have digitally that you know in bio
health and and epidemiology and the various other
forms of biosciences that you know we we just
sort of have gotten used to just being able to
download terabytes of data but on the other hand
there's so much data in a sense that's frozen in
print media and somebody just kind of has to
go in and mine it right but you have to like
literally go to that that giant building that's
on your campus it has books and there's people
there that will help you to find stuff you know
it's really kind of interesting to be able to
to think about all the untapped potential of the
University Library I guess no it's absolutely true
yeah well you know it does seem like a lot more
things are being digitized in different forms
so there may be you know there may be productive
things to think about there I haven't given that a
lot of thought but it is interesting how you know
a lot of stuff is no longer just printed it's at
least been scanned or something like that I think
you know we're catching up you know there's still
kind of a of a lag as the the interest kind of
goes backwards in time uh but you know eventually
we'll be like looking at historical Trends in
some of these things because we now have access
to data from you know those pulled out of the
literature from a generation or two ago that will
be interesting well Jennifer we've reached the
end of our hour thank you so much for sharing your
your work with us this is really really important
and I'm really glad that uh you're uh at the tip
of the spear on this so thank you so much for
sharing it with us we really enjoyed it and thank
you everyone for joining us and everyone have
a wonderful weekend and we'll see you next week